so we can't let you guys go without
asking for some season three teases so
we've we've kind of tried to weave our
way through
all the themes that we know and love
well from the karate kid but
is there any hidden corner of that movie
whether it's a theme or a certain detail
or something that you're just eager to
explore that you guys have yet to do
there's so much there's so much i mean
you know one of the things that we love
about season three
is the first time that ralph macchio was
actually
filming in okinawa because they shot
karate kid 2 in hawaii
so we get to know a little bit more
about mr miyagi and
you know we should take a moment and
just talk a little bit more about you
know pat maria's amazing performance
as you know the layers in that
performance that's one of those things
that you watch the movie as a kid and
then you watch it as you get older and
you realize just how special
that performance was and mr miyagi was a
character who
was troubled who was flawed who had
issues who like
you know wasn't eager to train daniel
russo in karate
the memories you have were like that
warm relationship that john
that that daniel and miyagi have but in
a sense if you
if you re-watch the karate kid and then
you watch
you know early episodes of cobra kai
there's sort of a similarity between
johnny's attitude about miguel and and
miyagi's attitude
about daniel in certain ways and you
know so those characters actually
overlapping
in quite quite a few ways and it's uh
you know one of the things that we love
about
you know season three is to be able to d
uh you know dig a little bit more into
the past of miyake's karate
and mr miyagi himself and that's only
one you know
one aspect you know because that's the
one that we've talked about we don't
want to get too into detail
with some of the other things except to
say one of
our one of the goals that we have when
we do the show
is to um to give greater
insight and depth into
the characters that we see in the
original movie and so
our hope is you know if you watch season
three
you'll go again back and watch karate
kid
in a new light even in in a different
way
than if you've seen the first two
seasons because we shed light on certain
things that
you know kind of in some ways set up the
original karate kid movie it's just
because we love these characters and we
want to know more about them and what
makes their heads tick
and you know you get little glimpses for
example of what johnny's life was like
and his home life was like uh on our
show in season one
which gives you something a new
perspective when you watch the original
i think
it's a similar thing in season three we
we have
moments on that show rather moments in
the season
that make you go back to the first movie
and look at it
in a new light and um not just
you know like john said one is with
miyagi but it's with
all the characters and it's it's really
uh
it's fun because you know we're telling
a new fresh story we have a lot of stuff
with
you know the younger actors that have
nothing to do with the past
but you can't escape the past and it's
it's
it's embedded in the story and in the
characters and to understand
the present and the future you kind of
have to go back into the past and
and work things out and and uncover new
things and that's what's fun about
season three
well there's a great lyric in in joe
esposito's uh
timeless song you're the best around
that says history repeats itself
and you know it's in there because that
song was composed for rocky
iii and it was literally supposed to be
history repeats itself as he's you know
fighting again
uh but they use it for the karate kid
where i don't think history had repeated
itself yet
at the time the song was on but by the
time
our audience is seeing season three of
cobra kai there is enough to
to play with now with that younger
generation especially looking back at
the movie
um and lots of characters realizing
what mistakes haven't been truly dealt
with
um what is left to evolve and
and how to fix the pain that we left
audiences you know
feeling that sucker punch of season of
the end of season two
um so we have a lot to answer for as uh
you know as the writers who put
everybody through that um
but i think it's going to be a very
satisfying uh season for people to
to bathe in when you look at the sequels
it's almost like they understood the
nostalgia back in the 1980s
if you look at crowded kid 2 and karate
kid 3 they're
they're doing a lot of what we're doing
they used you know
uh footage from karate kid1 in those
movies and
and you know they they really kept the
vibe
of the original going and there is more
to explore
you know with the sequels and you'll see
that in in season three and hopefully
beyond well there's there's something so
fun in looking
at the entire franchise as canon because
you know and the mechanics of actually
writing a franchise there are scenes
there are characters there are
choices in wardrobe and then what car
somebody's driving or what street they
live on
that are literally just a you make a
decision and you move on or it's just a
matter of getting a character from here
to there
but with the passage of time those
seemingly meaningless at times
choices become these treasures that we
pick up off the ground and we're like oh
my gosh
like if we lean into this this not only
becomes an episode it becomes a season
you start to see this like kind of
meadow of flowers that have grown
from the most meaningless of story
choices at times
um that that does give it a little bit
of that you know
this can this can go on and on which we
love because we have a lot of more story
to tell
we've always been the kinds of fans who
would watch a movie over and over
your favorite thing is like get him a
body bag was you know just
something that was thrown in to that
movie it's avr
exactly that wasn't even on set and it
became this line that like
people like us and fans all over the
world sort of connected with
and then when we're breaking story and
we're thinking okay we're gonna have
this you know
important episode where johnny and his
friends get together we're like you know
we wanted
it to be a poignant kind of episode and
we have like the most
meta joke of all time at the end when
when
you know tommy gets zipped up in the
body bag and it's sort of like taking
those little moments and building out a
story about
middle-aged friends who are experiencing
you know uh you know mortality and and
you know where you are and where you
where you where you're going uh
you know to take those that that moment
from the adr room and to
you know build a you know meaningful
story from it that's
you know it's the fun that we have and
it's the joke it's it's in a weird way
it's the joke of this whole show because
we're comedy writers first and foremost
so like
the fact that we're like you know
getting to do
it and then build full story out of it
is the greatest joy for us